as a sort of preview for how Trump
cultists May react in two weeks when
Trump is finally gone yesterday there
was a pro-trump rally in advance of
today's counting of the electoral votes
in Washington D.C and it is really
something to behold this is compelling
culturally
psychologically politically
scientifically it's really important for
us to understand that this contingent
these factions exist and they are very
radical uh to pretend that they don't
exist doesn't do us any good
it achieves nothing to pretend they
don't exist so let's look at some clips
and remember that the real Point here is
that it's a pro-trump rally to support
Donald Trump stealing the election from
Joe Biden now ostensively this is a
political rally saying Trump actually
won let's figure out how to take it okay
that's crazy but that's ostensibly what
this is but the way in which the Trump
was rigged stuff overlaps with
anti-vaccine nonsense it overlaps with
anti-Semitism of course it overlaps with
anti-science ideology it's important to
understand the sort of Venn diagram
because it confirms much of what
conspiracy experts have told us I've
interviewed many conspiracy experts on
the show
and they almost uh unanimously say some
conspiracy theories seem benign flatter
for example you believe the Earth is
flat you can't really do anything with
that you're not going to be able to push
people off the edge because there is no
Edge Etc but the point is that certain
people are just more prone to believe
conspiracies and so when we say Flat
Earth is benign okay but those same
people are predisposed to believe other
stuff that is more dangerous and has
more real world implications so let's
get right into it here is one speaker
referring to the deceptively named
biological agent known as a vaccine
that's a quote take a listen
not comply if you don't want to take an
experimental biological agent
deceptively named a vaccine you must not
allow yourself to be coerced
if you are living in fear of a
non-lethal virus simply by the same
cheap ordinary medicines used across the
world
when you know something to be false you
must reject it period when you know
something to be true you must stand up
for it and you must be willing to fight
for it I urge you to mark this day this
moment as a United return of our nation
to the Eternal Fight For Freedom a
commitment to Integrity a resolve to
seek the truth in all arenas and to
always act upon it Americans God Bless
America okay so that's pro-trump steal
the election Insanity merged with
anti-vaxx conspiracies that's one
example as to how these groups interact
all right here is pro-trump steal the
election stuff merging with more General
anti-communist Hugo Chavez conspiracy
theories which we've heard before who
knows that Sequoia a smartmatic and that
company was founded by Hugo Chavez and
communist Venezuela
step three your voice your votes were
exported and then of course much of this
also combining with the anti-science
stuff that directly leads to coveted
deaths and it's all kind of wrapped up
in this clip with religiosity because I
guess Jesus would say don't wear a mask
you tell me
so what I'm asking you to do right now
is to do the great reset in a good way
okay we're going to reframe it last
night about 150 of us went into Whole
Foods and we dressed up like people that
aren't idiots hiding from a virus that's
not deadly we did not wear a mask
who here is up to the task of not
wearing a mask
[Applause]
I ask you again who here is up to the
task of not wearing a mask
Jesus is King and it's time to Let
Freedom Ring ladies and gentlemen so
that's I guess claiming that the word of
God is not to wear masks
during a pandemic and that same guy also
claimed that covid tests are fake
what that even means I don't know but
let's take a listen the PCR
the Arts as you can hear the founder of
the PCR test Carrie Mullins explaining
to you the PCR tests are supposed to be
calibrated at 17. so I want you to write
those down 17 to 20 Cycles those are
calibrated at 40 Cycles what does that
mean it means that it's like your
speedometer is telling you you're
driving 400 miles an hour when you're
driving seven miles an hour so the covet
tests are fake that's that's actually a
new one and then we get into the
anti-Semitism now it's about George
Soros a Jewish man secretly controlling
Supreme Court Justices just a typical
anti-semitic dog whistle our next big
worker is one of the most fiery
activists I've ever known
she's tireless she's relentless
she will do research she's the only
person I know who does she watches
George Soros speeches for fun
but you know what happened when she
looked one of those up
she found that he was talking about
Chief Justice John Roberts like George
Soros owned him
Lynnwood retweeted it far
she gets this information because she
never stops fighting George Soros is
controlling
John Roberts George Soros is the real
puppet master of the Chief Justice of
the Supreme Court that's the idea and as
I've said before you have to know what
you're listening for that's the thing
about dog whistles it's much like when
you blow a dog whistle the dog has ears
tuned to hear it so they hear the
whistle it's the same thing with these
anti-semitic tropes and dog whistles you
have to understand the context and what
what they're referring to and then
lastly Alex Jones doesn't need much of
an introduction not looking good not
sounding good but saying very very wild
things we don't quietly take the
election fraud we don't quietly take the
scam and believe their BS we've seen the
evidence
the system has had to desperately engage
in this Gambit to maintain control but
this will be their Waterloo this will be
their destruction
whatever happens to president Trump in
15 days
he is still the elected president of
this Republic and we do not recognize
the Communist Chinese agent Joe Biden or
his controllers
yeah so that's uh again it's either a
character that he's playing or a very
very sick guy so my question I sort of
have a short term and a medium-term
question on these folks short term is
what do they do tomorrow when the vote
will have been certified uh the
electoral vote will have been counted in
the House and Senate for Joe Biden what
do they do on January 20th when Trump
leaves do they get violent what happens
that's the short-term question the more
medium-term question is do these people
even stay engaged with the political
world many of them were never engaged
before Trump they were sort they sort of
joined politics
um directly into the Trump cult and I
don't know the answer as to whether they
just get out of politics or they stay
and much of it might depend on what
Trump does for the next two or four
years does Trump remain engaged in
politics or does he disappear to
wherever we'll allow him and just kind
of play golf and sit around questions we
don't yet have answers to and we'll
continue covering this uh and these
events on our Instagram where you can
find us at davidpackman show a lot of
the shirts you see me wearing on YouTube
are actually made by a company called
Teddy Stratford I love these shirts and
that's why I asked them to be a sponsor
of the show it really is the most
Innovative shirt you can buy because
most slim fit button-up shirts give you
this weird stretched out Gap in the
chest where the buttons are you don't
get that with the teddy Stratford shirts
because all of their shirts come with a
patented zipper hidden beneath the
buttons which prevents the chest from
stretching apart like that but most
importantly just overall it makes the
shirt fit much better and look better
the carefully designed shirt is also cut
in a way that improves the look of your
upper body physique it has a really nice
elegant close fit that other shirts
don't really give you it also has a
specially designed collar that won't
fall down and lay flat which I love the
difference all around with these shirts
really is noticeable go check them out
at davidpackman.com Teddy the link is
down below and they'll give you 15 off
your first order if you use the coupon
code Pacman at checkout